i i want to be a leader in my house and
we understand women are
er
er getting more masculine they want to
get in education their feminism movement
we understand that so we have this
agreement let's compete in the house you
can you can study you can do all these
things um let's compete in the house we
have a healthy competition and i still
want to be on top and i'm down to
compete so we have a healthy competition
at home i always want to leave the house
well if let's well she doesn't uh
i know how to make money but i don't
know how to save it so i don't have a
wallet she manages my money she manages
the money we make it together really
really brother
i know you're the maker she's the saver
she's the wallet she's the
administrator really
today she told me i give you the i gave
you the payroll give me some money back
and i'm like
because i want to spend it all
and and when she met me brother i was
broke i was a broke artist i was very
ambitious i've always been successful
but i always spend all my money
so we're a team brother what would you
spend it on anything anything i won
anything i wanted because i know by the
way i i was homeless when
rabbit hole on this because you're
talking to somebody that makes a good
amount of money okay and i say invest in
me a lot of money okay oh and i'd save
and i invest adam this is a invest in me
let's buy a plane let's trap let's
travel the world we're working on that
and make people happy but but what is it
about you when you make let's say you
make six figures we kill it all right we
had an amazing month we made 100 grand
whatever do you feel like there's a hole
in your pocket i gotta go spend it i
want to have the time of my life i want
to have an experience i want to buy new
things what is it about the money word
that is burning a hole in your pocket
because he knows how to make it so
quickly so it doesn't matter to him he's
like i'll just make it again i was
homeless when you talk rock bottom bro
everything is like yeah you live in a
borrowed time yes you're living on
borrowed time so i'm not afraid of money
i don't care about money
if whenever i want to save it i'll save
it
so and now also very i'm very
disciplined i'm very disciplined so i i
like to be on the edge all the time
forcing myself to
to to to show myself that i'm i'm not
gonna drown and i teach people how not
to drown brother too
because people like to drown and and
when you don't have enough challenge at
home you know you don't know how to you
don't know how to exhale and you say
that people like to drown well yeah
depression is drowning
depression is drowning i think and
depression can be a comfort zone if
that's what they know they want to stay
there and they're miserable but that's
the only thing they know so they stay
there the victim mentality
don't victimize yourself bro do
something anything go out it's like
you've seen this the movie shawshank
redemption yeah where he get they say
you can go out you can leave the jail
he's like no this is all i know uh-huh
exactly i want to stay in the jail it's
like go you could be free
exactly challenge yourself right so but
it sounds like you've met this beautiful
girl
yes and she's like
we're going to save some of that money
yeah we're going to use this for our
business i'm going to be i'm going to
compete with you to show you just how
much money you make i could save yeah
and i can do good things
i've never been homeless i come from a
very wholesome house household and i've
never struggled with money like the way
he has so i am afraid of staying without
money i'm afraid of being broke so i
don't want to spend my money i always
want to have like a safety net if
something happens and there's like a
whatever i want to have something to
fall on yeah that was an important
statement that you're not being afraid
of money people or
money there was a podcast with jake paul
and um they asked him like when you made
your first million dollars like how did
you feel were you excited and he said
that he was actually really scared
he said he was scared to see all that
money in his account like he didn't want
to lose it so like i could see why you
would spend all your money because you
can come from nothing and be able to
make it versus somebody's like oh my
gosh so you know i don't know if i'm
gonna be able to get this again like and
that's i think important for people to
understand those two realities and like
that is where your discipline is is what
happens is that people like to you know
save resources save resources and then
like when i have all these resources i'm
going to do all these things and is that
it's like
you're never going to do those things
you might die you say you're going to do
those things and you find a way brother
you're fine
he does it the other way around he's
like when you do everything it's like
when you buy a house you don't save the
money to buy a house you ask for a loan
you get the house and then you pay it so
he works like that he's like i'll just
buy the freaking 3 000 camera and then
we'll figure it out and i'll say i want
this and then i focus obsessively i
think i'm a little autistic so i'm
obsessively i don't know i don't stop
until i conquer
so
it's just math i don't believe in talent
either it's a good it's a good balance
between you guys
that's what i was going to say is that
you have this like
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll figure it out
mentality
where it's like the yin and yang thing
you guys got going on is that why your
relationship works so well yeah we're
very different yeah okay we're very very
romantic and very intense and things
have meanings and stuff yeah and i'm
like okay let's go wake up let's go work
out let's do what we have to do and
things don't really have that much of a
meaning for me really it's that's almost
the opposite of how a female and a male
oh
yeah
we're so opposite and you said you've
been together how long now 12 years 12
years yeah so you met when you were kids
basically yeah yeah yeah we were 27 yeah
so um explain the dynamic household
living uh
you know trust jealousy i'm shooting
with beautiful women i manage the money
you you said that you have brutal
honesty with your wife explain the
dynamic in the relationship and uh how
that operates and what kind of fights do
you guys even get i know that's a very
loaded question yeah but give me the
good the bad the ugly of your beautiful
relationship
our fights are uh mostly because we have
different wants and needs so we have we
we got married through the commitment of
religion marriage we have a regular
marriage
so we but we don't believe in
we don't have the same
variables i don't know how to explain
this i don't know what you're trying to
say
we have this idea
i'm a person and i want my things
friend will you help me conquer my
things yes and i'll help you yours so
we're a team team i love that so
different things
yeah yeah we do this forever sure yeah
we used to think i mean that's what they
taught us when we were kids we were you
know two you're a half of fun what an
orange and you're looking for your other
half i don't need another half i'm a
full
grown person i don't need him i want him
and that's different so if i tell him
what i want we can conquer it together
obviously their their rules or their
limits or whatever and if i tell him
like i want this and he he doesn't feel
comfortable let's talk about it but i
get uncomfortable let's get to a middle
pond where we both feel comfortable i
don't you know i don't
cross any boundaries but also i don't eh
how do you say that like stop you from
growing or doing whatever you want let's
find a way that you can do whatever you
want and i feel comfortable or a little
uncomfortable in the process but i'm
okay with it that way you don't have to
lie to me we don't have anything you
have to say no i don't want that that
because my wife is going no no no you
want it let's find a way to make it work
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]